la droite et le centre yvelinois
rassembler autour de gérard larcher à
l'initiative du président du sénat en
collaboration avec pierre bédier une
convention autour des républicains s'est
tenue vendredi 12 juillet objectif
réfléchir sur les enjeux de la santé
nous pensons qu'il faut repartir du
territoriale du local de toutes ces
innovations que nous avons entendu cet
après midi autour du thème de la santé
des initiatives pour inverser la
verticalité de la décision politique
nous croyons profondément une nouvelle
génération de la décentralisation c'est
aussi pour moi
vous l'avez vu symboliquement de
rassembler l'ensemble de celles et de
ceux qui parfois sont séparés une
présence symbolique ce rassemblement
valérie pécresse présidente de la région
ile de france à la tête de son mouvement
libre elle qui a quitté le parti des
républicains le 5 juin dernier
j'inscris le mouvement libre sous
l'ombrelle protectrice de gérard larcher
je pense qu'il faut rénover le logiciel
de penser de la droite s'allier avec le
centre et tout ça est bien avec libre
nous y travaillons et nous y travaillons
grâce à gérard larcher en bonne
intelligence avec les républicains en
bonne intelligence avec les centristes
pour cette convention de la droite et du
centre dans les yvelines le président du
département pierre bédier affiche sa
volonté de transférer la compétence
santé au niveau du département dans le
prochain acte de décentralisation s'est
suffisamment puissant un département
pour pouvoir porter des politiques mais
c'est aussi suffisamment proche des
habitants des élus des élus de premier
rang que sont les maires pour pouvoir là
aussi apporter des réponses en toile de
fond de cette convention les municipales
de 2020 pierre bédier a annoncé proposer
un label ensemble pour les yvelines tout
comme karl olive a proposé le label de
son mouvement génération terrain un
scrutin qui aura lieu le 15 et 22 mars
prochains